[Musique]
vers la fin du moyen âge les états
pontificaux sont une puissante
seigneurie de la péninsule italique les
papes au sel une redoutable armée et
couronnent les rois d'europe mais ils
interdisent la lecture de la bible
emprisonnant quiconque s'y essaient
la ville de florence aussi est une
puissante seigneurie
le florin est une monnaie très forte et
les érudits florentin forment l'élite de
la culture européenne
[Musique]
l'un de ces érudits dante alighieri
aimerait bien savoir ce qui est écrit
dans la bible
[Musique]
à cette époque il est dangereux d'aller
contre les dogmes catholiques mais dans
tu adores ce qui est interdit et se fait
initier à la société secrète de son ami
guy d'eau cavale tanti un savant qui
connaît énormément de choses interdites
dante découvre alors que depuis
l'antiquité des initiés arabes se
transmettent en secret les données d'une
ancienne technologie très avancée
les données originales sont gravés sur
des tablettes d'argile et ensuite de
copier et traduites sur du papyrus mais
très rares sont ceux qui comprennent les
notions répertorier ces écrits parle
d'habitants d'autres planètes
[Musique]
deschacht roland d'armes foudroyante
de communication visuelle entre
personnes d'endroits éloigné de
manipulation médical avec un singe dont
le résultat est l'homme
dante tressailli il veut tout savoir sur
ces textes il se plonge alors dans leurs
lectures et découvre un monde
fantastique
les écrits raconte qu'il y a quatre cent
mille ans une flotte de chars volant
avec à bord des géants rentrer dans
notre système solaire forme des
comptoirs sur mars et sur la lune et
arrive sur la terre se pose en
mésopotamie
ces géants appelé hanouna qui disent
provenir de la planète denis bis rue et
sont six ans entre mâles et femelles
[Musique]
leur équipe est composée de noble de
militaires et de scientifiques à la
technologie très avancée
ils bâtissent leurs bases terrestres en
mésopotamie ainsi qu'un grand site
d'extraction de minerais au sud de
l'afrique
ayant besoin de main d'oeuvre les
hanouna qui préfèrent dupliquer en
laboratoire des animaux aptes au travail
dans les mines
plutôt que de fabriquer les automates en
métal
il un ces mines dont en laboratoire avec
leurs propres semences une primates
africaine et après les essais celles-ci
génèrent le premier homme
[Musique]
c'est un mal bon pour tous travaux mais
il est stérile
[Musique]
pour qu'ils se duplique tout seul sans
l'aide du laboratoire les médecins
hanouna qui le rend alors fertile et lui
ajoute la femme
pendant cent mille ans au fur et à
mesure que les hommes et les femmes se
multiplient les hanouna qui ne
transportent aux quatre coins du monde
formant les premières grandes
agglomérations humaines de la
préhistoire
mais durant les cent mille ans qui
suivent le nord gel et quand la
glaciation s'achève un grand déluge
submerge le monde
les hanouna qui s'envole sur leur char
mais la plupart des êtres humains et
noyées par les eaux
c'est un désastre ne survivent que les
hommes réfugiés sur les montagnes et la
famille 2,8 soudera abrité dans une
arche
quand les eaux se retirent les hanouna
qui reviennent en mésopotamie réparé les
dégâts de leur structure et se re
partage la terre émergée pour y fonder
de nouvelles nations apparaissent
simultanément en mésopotamie en egypte
dans la vallée de l'indus en chine et en
amérique centrale
les premières grandes civilisations
d'après le déluge
ayant besoin de travailleurs pour bâtir
les nouvelles villes les hanouna qui
capture les hommes et les femmes ayant
survécu au déluge et les domestiques les
rendant sédentaires mais chasse les plus
sauvages qui vont former des tribus
nomades
[Musique]
dans les villes les hommes côtoient les
hanouna qui et les considèrent comme des
divinités
mais s'il s'approche sans protection de
leur formidable arme moeurs fulgurant
[Musique]
les hanouna qui fusionne alors la pierre
à la façon du volcan et la modèles sur
mesure faisant construire aux hommes de
colossales mur anti sismiques ou garder
les armes et des pyramides blanche
visible du ciel pour en signaler la
position
[Musique]
pour nourrir leurs nombreux ouvriers les
hanouna qui construisent dans chaque
nation des normes chant clôture est voué
à l'agriculture et à l'élevage dans ses
champs les médecins hanouna qui modifie
les plantes et les animaux sauvages des
alentours les adaptant aux régimes
alimentaires des travailleurs
sédentaires
[Musique]
l'un de ses champs clôturer l eden
lors du partage du monde
le puissant hanouna qui marc duc reçoit
la mésopotamie et construit les dden au
nord de son domaine entre la mer noire
et la mer caspienne
[Musique]
ayant besoin de personnel pour les dden
marc duc fait capturer et domestique et
un millier d'hommes et de femmes
primitif ses captifs appelé adami tu
travailles dur mais ils ont leur pas
assuré et une vie sans prédateur de plus
l' extraordinaire technologie hanouna
qui accroît les capacités de
compréhension d adam it est en fait une
espèce d'homme plus évolué la seule
précaution à prendre est de se raser le
crâne car les halles où naquit mal
s'excite à la vue de cheveux longs et ne
font pas de distinction entre femmes et
hommes
[Musique]
il y a cinq mille ans les hanouna qui
décide de quitter la terre afin qu'en
leur absence la vie humaine reste la
plus confortable possible
il dicte des données scientifiques aux
érudits de chaque nation dans l'éden
aussi ces données sont dictées aux
érudits adam it kills et transcrivent
fidèlement sur des tablettes d'argile
quand les hanouna qui partent les
annamites savent faire plein de choses
mais ne savent pas combattre ni se
défendre les hommes primitifs prennent
d'assaut les dden pour le dépouiller de
ses richesses et les annamites sont
obligés de s'enfuir
[Musique]
une cinquantaine de leur clan dont les
membres sont identifiables par la tête
rasée quitte alors les dden et se dirige
tout droit vers les vestiges hanouna qui
en basse mésopotamie entre les fleuves
tigre et euphrate
ils remettent en fonction les machines
abandonné et bâtissent une citadelle
royale pour chaque clan
l'ensemble de ces petits royaumes et
sumer les adam it sont donc appelés
sumériens et leurs premières villes sont
quiche centre politique et ni pur centre
religieux et demeure de la luna qui n
lille l'oncle très puissant de marc duc
[Musique]
quand dante termine sa lecture il est
fasciné tout autant que cavalcanti très
intrigués par ce que les sumériens
affirme que la terre est ronde et
qu'elle tourne autour du soleil
cet ancien peuple maîtrise l'astronomie
la physique
la chimie la médecine la métallurgie
l'ingéniérie larchitecture la
minéralogie et la zoologie et même la
parfumerie
les sumériens sont également champions
des mathématiques basant leurs calculs
sur le nombre 60
ils inventent leur et les minutes
ils utilisent les systèmes numériques
métrologique âgées briques géométriques
et calcul très exactement l'espace
[Musique]
pour administrer leurs économies
ils produisent deux petits sauts
cylindres en pierre a déroulé sur
l'argile afin de prendre l'empreinte du
dessin et dépasse la transmission orale
en inventant l'écriture qu'ils gravent
sur des tablettes d'argile
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que les sumériens racontent
leurs histoires de vie leur commerce et
leur mythe précisant bien que les
détenteurs du savoir scientifique ne
sont pas eux mais les halles où naquit
[Musique]
les villes sumérienne sont riches et
cela attire les acadiens un peuple c'est
mythique du nord
[Musique]
les sumériens ont besoin d'ouvriers et
accueille volontiers ces primitifs
chevelu et barbu mais quand les acadiens
deviennent majoritaires leur roi sargon
renverse les cité sumérienne et forment
le premier empire de l'histoire au
siècle suivant les sumériens reprennent
le pouvoir
leroy architectes de guider à guy de la
renaissance sumérienne et les rois sully
et urnes à mu fonde sur la nouvelle
capitale de sumer
la civilisation sumérienne dure près de
deux mille ans quand l'immigration
massive d'un autres peuples sémitiques
les amorites cause son déclin définitif
[Musique]
babylone se fait l'héritière de sumer et
assimile certaines de ces technologies
mais les guerres et les saccages
détruisent ces lieux historiques de
mésopotamie enterrant les tablettes
sumériennes et leur savoir dans le
désert du califat de bagdad
cavalcanti soutient cependant que
l'ancien connaissance ce n'est pas perdu
à la chute de sumer ces érudits avait
transcrit les données des tablettes sur
des rouleaux de papyrus et s'étaient
enfuis à main fils où ils s'étaient unis
à des savants égyptien formant une
société secrète
[Musique]
le secret était nécessaire étant donné
que dans de mauvaises mains
la technologie hanouna qui aurait été
utilisée pour détruire les peuples
plutôt que pour guérir les maladies
[Musique]
à l'image des descendants du sumérien
jacob ils utilisèrent la technologie
hanouna qui pour exterminer les peuples
au cours de leur voyage vers la
palestine où ils fondèrent le royaume
d'israël
la bible hébraïque raconte ce voyage
citant les hanouna qui appelait elohim
et les mêmes événements graves et deux
mille ans auparavant sur les tablettes
sumériennes
[Musique]
cavalcanti explique adam tu que les
anciens textes égyptiens grecs hébraïque
et latins sont tous des remaniements des
écrits sumériens
[Musique]
en egypte aussi les conflits font rage
les nubiens et les perses anéantissent
l'état égyptien obligeant la société
secrète de même fils à se déplacer en
grèce
cavalcanti est convaincu que depuis
l'arrivée des initiés égyptien en grèce
le savoir grec a accompli un saut
formidable
pythagore le premier grec à être initié
par cette société secrète perçoit dans
les écrits sumériens un système de
calcul des angles et invente le théorème
de géométrie qui l'a rendu fameux
aristote est un initié qui étudie la
matière et c'est lui qui initie le jeune
le cleee d'1 mètre des mathématiques et
de la géométrie
archimède aussi est un initié de cette
société secrète persan certaines notions
sumérienne il en extrait les concepts de
physique de la mécanique et de l'hydro
statique
au fil des siècles la grèce et l'egypte
sont annexés par le prospère empires
romain byzantin
la société secrète ce transfert alors à
alexandrie centre du savoir
philosophique et mathématiques de
l'époque et donne un coup d'accélération
aux sciences appliquées et aux
mathématiques arabe
quand les musulmans occupent l'espagne
les initiés arabe passe le relais à
leurs disciples espagnol et de là le
secret des sumériens arrive à florence
[Musique]
il
dante est fasciné
cette histoire d être venu de l'espace
et de leurs technologies
il inspire dans sa divine comédie il
cite alors des notions techniques
qu'aucun à son époque ne pouvais même
imaginer il décrit l'absence de poids
dans l'habitacle du char céleste qui les
transportent lui et béatrice vers la
planète de dieu
ce char céleste vol à une vitesse
infiniment plus grande que celle de la
lumière et son parcours dans notre
système solaire est en sens inverse le
même que celui des ânes ou là qui décrit
sur les tablettes sumériennes
[Musique]
le secret reste à florence où
l'animateur de la renaissance italienne
l'initié mars il est fils 1 passe le
relais à léonard de vinci
[Musique]
léonard s'intéresse fort aux notions
mécanique des sumériens et comprend
alors que voler est vraiment possible
cependant léonard ne réussit pas à voler
malgré son génie il n'avait que les
jambes et les bras comme moteur
[Musique]
à cette époque les anciens mythes refont
surface avec la terre d'arcadie où les
bergers se transmettent un savoir
scientifique au culte mais l'inquisition
accuse d'hérésie tout ce qui touche à
des nouveautés scientifiques
pendant deux siècles le secret se
dissipe très peu quand en 1849 un
événement crucial secoue le monde
scientifique
des fouilles archéologiques mettre à
jour publiquement des milliers de
tablettes sumériennes enterré dans la
bibliothèque du très savant roi
d'assyrie à suhr banny pâle
depuis cette date la technologie fait le
bond le plus impressionnant de
l'histoire
les moyens inconcevable tels que
l'électricité la radio le téléphone
le moteur et même l'avion sont
soudainement inventé
[Musique]
les armements passe du mousquet homicide
l'une après l'autre de guerre mondiale
éclate
les nazis construisait en secret un
prototype de vaisseau spatial utilisant
lentilles gravité et élimine ceux qui en
parlent
albert einstein alerte le monde sur
l'évolution nucléaire des nazis et
l'ingénieur spatiale von braun déclare
que la technologie avancée des allemands
ne vient pas de leur intelligence mais
d'un ancien savoir révélé
la russie ouvre l'ère spatiale lançons
le premier satellite artificiel de
l'histoire le scout nick un gardant
secret ses inventeurs le vatican
construite en arizona le plus grand
télescope du monde pour scruter le
cosmos à la recherche de vie
extraterrestre
en peu de temps il ya eu la promenade
sur la lune la manipulation génétique
les ordinateurs
internet l'interconnexion vidéo
[Musique]
comment avons-nous fait tout cela dans
un laps de temps si court
[Musique]
la réponse est peut-être dans les
tablettes sumériennes puisqu'elle
décrivent tous ses inventions
le souhait des hanouna qui quand ils ont
transmis aux hommes leur notion
scientifique se réalisera dont peut-être
si la pollution ne nous empoisonnent pas
et si le nucléaire ne fait pas exploser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors nous devrons remercier les
sumériens pour n'en être pas rester à
l'âge du bronze